welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and Avengers Kang Dynasty just made
a big shift by hiring a new writer the
screenwriter currently working on
Avengers Secret Wars and the one brought
in to launch this Multiverse Saga back
in Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness and in Loki Michael Waldren this
is a big deal it tells us that Marvel
Studios has so much confidence in the
way all of this kicked off with Reed
Richard's conversation with Doctor
Strange about incursions in Multiverse
of Madness as well as the alternate
Infinity War sequence with the
Illuminati having killed Thanos and the
way Waldron has already been setting up
events in secret Wars that they need
that same brain to connect a to c and
since Sam Ry is rumored to be the top
Contender to direct Secret Wars and now
destined Daniel keton has left Kang
Dynasty it kind of feels like Marvel
wants a team of creatives who best know
how to slaughter multiversal Heroes
while they nerd out about incursions so
did Marvel Studios bring in a creative
Hitman to assassinate Wolverine to
McGuire Peter Parker and all those MCU
phase four and five Heroes who didn't
like work out too well in this video I'm
going to break down exactly what the job
of these screenwriters contracted by
Marvel Studios is to do because there is
so much misinformation online about this
and what walren really did on lokis C's
1 and Multiverse of Menace and I'm going
to break down what it really means that
wal is writing both Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars at the same time together by
the way bit of an announcement here I
will soon be going on paternity leave
because our baby is coming early folks
you will still see me on the new
Rockstar channel in some pre-taped
videos and I know you're really going to
like but coming back to cover for me is
Jessica Clemens you're going to see
Jessica on the channel in the next month
along with some other familiar faces so
please show them the love and support
that you've always shown me and I cannot
wait to watch their videos at 4:00 a.m.
every night as I try to get my baby to
fall back asleep okay Marvel brought in
Michael walren to take over scripting
duties of Avengers King Dynasty after
parting ways with a previous
screenwriter jeff lovess which you know
we were all pretty bummed to see because
he's also a great writer who I think
really did the best he could with
quantam Mania and I hope someday we can
read whatever his treatment or his
outline or his script draft was for King
Dynasty but like Jeff lovess Michael
walren first came into Marvel from the
Rick and Morty writers room and Waldren
became head writer of Loki season 1 but
he left before the end of the season was
fully finished and we later found out
some of the rewrites were overseen by
Eric Martin who is the head writer for
Loki season 2 now there has been some
very silly griping on social media about
Michael Waldren mostly from people who I
guess are mad about some parts of
Multiverse of Madness and some claim
that Eric Martin should get these
writing jobs and not Michael Waldren can
we please just stop it look Eric Martin
is clearly a really good writer he's
going to get a lot of work from Marvel
and everywhere from here forward we were
not in the Loki season 1 riters room we
don't know who wrote what who shaped
what but we do know that that room
worked really well together and came up
with some brilliant in the Loki as
symbl documentary there are some
interesting shots of Waldren standing in
front of dry erase board outlining early
versions of episodes and in that
foreground yep that's Eric Martin but
running the room clearly making notes on
the board is walren though ultimately
this was a team effort and all of these
guys know how to collaborate together to
craft a story and how to pull away alone
for a few weeks to crank out great
drafts on their own that's what Eric
Martin did when Marvel nuked his episode
5 idea for loky season 2 he basically
had a weekend to just come up with a new
script draft and what episode 5 ended
being was actually pretty good but that
professionalism that writers room
collaborative energy sharpened when
these particular writers worked on Rick
and Morty and Dan Harman kept them in
that room late into the night to do
rewrite after rewrite these guys just
kind of had to figure out how to keep
old man Haron sitting in the corner
shooting down all their story ideas and
saying already saw that in an episode of
Doctor Who 30 years ago it's it's cool
RI Doctor Who in this mother and that
experience transformed all of them as
well as Jessica gal who wrote pickle
Rick before she was headwriter of
She-Hulk into some of the most inventive
solution finders in this industry so it
wasn't like Rick and Morty sophomoric
Pooh jokes burped into a microphone by
Justin royland but the Geniuses behind
the scenes of Rick and Morty who figured
out how to unpaint themselves out of Any
Corner Marvel was right to recruit These
Guys these collaborative skills are
critical
especially for the way Marvel Studios
operates when you read MCU the reign of
Marvel Studios by Joanna Robinson Dave
Gonzalez and Gavin Edwards it is clear
that the studio needs creative
collaborators like the Russo brothers
who also worked with Dan Haron in
episodes of Community screenwriters like
Marcus and mcy and contrastingly when
solo utter come into Marvel Studios and
aren't as effective at rolling with the
punches things like their final battles
already being prevised out for them or a
second unit director knowing how to
shoot stunt action better than they do
you can kind of see some friction for or
directors like taoi just saying H I
don't really care what you do with it so
you know what bad habits have a bad
habit of sticking around fighting them
is hard but transforming something like
Doom scrolling from a bad habit to a
good one is easy thanks to fume fume
makes it possible to replace your bad
habits with good ones that you are free
to enjoy it's an Innovative award-
nominated device with no electronics no
vapor and no harmful chemicals fume is
completely natural and it uses all
natural ingredients to give you a birth
burst of delicious flavored air and fume
is super fidgety which is helpful for
de-stressing while you break your old
habit each device has an adjustable air
flow dial and it's designed with movable
parts and magnets using fume just gives
you a nice moment just for yourself
crisp mint makes my brain think I'm
sitting on a porch sipping a julip and
maple pepper gives me a strong weakened
brunch Vibe even if I'm just waiting to
cross the street and working moments
like that into your routine is a good
habit stopping is all something we put
off because it's hard but switching to
fume is easy enjoyable and even fun fume
has served over 150,000 customers and
has thousands of success stories and
there's no reason you can't be one of
them join fume in accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to trif nume.com and use code
new rockstars to save 10% off when you
get the journey pack today that's TR
fm.com and use code new rockstars to
save an additional 10% off your order
today so when you look at these behind
the scenes images in the writers room of
Loki season 1 and you Tred to zuder who
writing what don't worry about that just
look at the Joy shared between these
writers and the creative chemistry of a
group of writers figuring out a great
story and speaking of that story look
closely at the notes on the stri race
for I love it walren structured the
outline in a circle using Dan Harmon's
dactic story structural episodic outline
structure that he forces every episode
of Rick and Morty to abide by and this
is outlined in an alternate episode one
of the Loki Series in which Loki steals
all the Infinity Stones he acquired the
Throne of Asgard and then he gets
infected by the thought that none of it
is real and returns to the TVA that
Destiny of Loki acquiring his throne was
always in the DNA of this show in the
back of the minds of these writers Eric
Martin brought Loki full circle at the
end of season 2 and Waldren always
wanted to go there and now in the MCU he
has a Loki on a throne now we should be
clear these guys are talented writers
but you know they're not gods of story
Loki season 2 left quite a few things
underdeveloped sylv's journey in season
2 Rand Slayer Mobius is Destiny when
asked about these in interviews Eric
Martin is just kind of like I don't know
we didn't write it I think the strength
of a writer is coming up with a story
that is so good that when you first
watch it you don't really care about the
flaws in the story it shows that they
know what the priorities are so what
does Michael Waldren writing the next
two Avengers movies mean for this story
well obviously it tells us these movies
really will be kind of like an Infinity
war and endgame style two-part event
Kang Dynasty will end in a kind of
defeat or Cliffhanger Secret Wars will
resolve it with a huge battle sequence
and when you dive into what exactly
Michael walren changed for Multiverse
Madness when he was assigned to that
script he has said in interviews that
the Illuminati Massacre was in his very
first drafted the script that is
something he brought to the table he
cited the Space Marines massacre in
James Cameron's aliens as one of his
favorite sequences it just fills you
with Dread and I totally agree now when
it came to which Illuminati that they
were going to include in the sequence
they apparently discussed a million
people and he said that Kevin fi
ultimately handpicked who was and who
wasn't on the deas now later we learn
from concept art in previous footage
that Daniel Craig as balder the brave
Thor's brother was going to be in that
seventh empty chair and with the Loki
writers in season 2 including a shout
out to balder in the World's Fair
episode I think we are going to see
balder in Kang Dynasty and or Secret
Wars so beyond that four conclusions I
think we can draw from Waldron's role in
Avengers Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
one Kang Dynasty is going to be a doctor
strange centered story especially if Sam
Ry is coming back to direct these movies
I think Marvel is looking at their
landscape and realizing nah Doctor
Strange is our frontman two the dialogue
that walren wrote for Reed Richards to
explain what incursions are which was
adapted from Jonathan Hickman's speech
from the comics Reed Richards in the
time Runs Out story line that is going
to continue to be the basis for the
Multiverse logic and Kang Dynasty in
secret Wars like we're going to find out
that this Multiverse was destined to
collide this is on its natural course to
do so and that each character in the MCU
has been unknowingly influencing that
Destiny Loki Sylvie Peter Parker Doctor
Strange Clea Kamala Khan wand maximoff
they have all damaged the fabric of
reality in different ways but but that
it was Kang who was the one who
exploited that chaos and really
encouraged it third implication Heroes
will die brutally we've been assuming
that Deadpool 3 is going to be a
storyline like Deadpool kills the fox
Universe I think Kang Dynasty is going
to build on that and finally show Kang
slaughtering Marvel heroes from past
eras in quamania he referenced that he
had killed the Thor with a hammer we
need to see that happen I think Kang's
going to take down all the big heroes
from the past maybe a past Peter Parker
maybe a past Daredevil who might have
been bit too handsome and I'm not
talking about their necks being snapped
by the Scarlet Witch I'm talking about
what Scarlet Witch did to the most
lethal of these threats Reed Richards
spaghetti vacation my friends the way
Victor timely was again and again and
again Kang already promised that he
would do something like this but he
described it this way and I will burn
them out of time for what they've done
to me and fourth implication Loki it's
coming back folks Waldren said in
interviews that while writing Multiverse
of madness he was desperate to try to
get Loki in there now this guy is more
more control over the story and I think
Avengers King Dynasty and Secret Wars
will be a rescue mission for the god of
stories to relieve him of his atlases
duty by ending the threat of all kangs
across the Multiverse thank you so much
for continuing to support new rock stars
during my paternity leave and show
Jessica Clement some love as she covers
for me she's going to do a great job
I'll be back in a few weeks thanks for
watching I'll see you soon
[Music]
bye
n